The Joe Rogan experience.
Yeah.
Wrestlers in particular wrestlers are so good at many of you.
Do you see that Jordan Burroughs?
Ben Asked her match last night.
Fucking credible.
How good is that Guy Jordan,
the boss to do that to a guy like Ben ask Ryan.
I mean it just shows you Ben hasn't competed I think in nine years,
but Ben is one of the greatest,
I mean I'm a huge fan of his wrestling.
It's so interesting.
I think that is like the worst matchup for Ben Asker I think because you're
taking,
uh,
one of the most creative wrestlers ever been been asked her and I don't want to
over over overstate it,
but he has incredibly creative,
one of the great pinning wrestler.
So he pins people he like confuses them and pins them incredibly well.
And you,
you put them against basically a freak blast,
double like the greatest double leg take down maybe of all time.
All time.
There was like somebody put a clip up that said,
uh,
is this it?
Yeah.
So when you put a clip of,
Oh shit,
he went off the fucking Matt into the crowd.
That's pretty,
that was the best part.
As he defended a take down.
Those are the best part.
That's crazy,
man,
that they,
they have such a drop off with these guys.
Like you shouldn't really have a platform like that where a guy could fall off
into the crowd.
That seems so stupid.
It rarely happens.
What the fuck are you talking about?
It just happened.
Rarely happens.
They rarely have these.
It's true.
This is our,
but that's a terrible thing.
How that shit flat on the ground.
That is so dumb.
I can't even believe they did that.
I think this whole mass should be contested.
It doesn't count.
Well I don't,
I don't,
you know,
I think,
look,
that's stupid.
That's not smart devil.
A guy who's a fucking powerhouse of a blast,
double hitting you and sending you flying to the cause.
That's crazy.
That is crazy that they didn't have anything in place to stop that.
That's the reason why wrestling takes place on the ground.
You fucking assholes.
And why do you haven't people wrestle on a platform?
That's why is this show,
so the,
the,
the whole show,
you can have a show where it's on a board.
It's on the grounds called basketball.
Yeah.
It's on the ground.
I mean it was worrying because Vanessa and I said,
and I'm a fighter and you got injured with that right there.
Right there.
It could have torn his lead Nia part easily.
Well the silver lining is that he's okay.
Yeah.
The silver lining.
And uh,
and we got to see that,
you know,
it was interesting Jordan Burroughs had on his Instagram,
there's levels to this,
you know,
they're raising his hand up and let's like that's what we got to see.
Cause Ben is a phenomenal wrestler.
But you're right,
he hasn't competed in a long time.
He's not necessarily at the level that he was back then.
Even though he's incredible for MMA standards.
It's good to see like it's good.
It's good to see that with boxing it's good to see that with anything like when
Floyd,
man Mayweather fought Conor,
I think it was good to see that,
that there are really levels to this.
And the interesting thing about German borrowers,
I think he's so good that he's probably going to stay out of MMA.
That's so crazy.
But there are some,
here's some clips of it,
but yeah,
we can't show it to a t you people.
But uh,
who,
who put this on flow wrestling,
flow,
wrestling,
put this on.
I wonder if people are pirating it online or if they,
they put it online.
If they're allowing and no,
they,
well,
people are pirating it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Good luck stopping that.
Right.
Well,
I think people should support flow wrestling though though.
They do have like a,
um,
I'm a member.
Are you,
oh,
look at this.
Look at this to God.
He's good.
Yeah,
man.
So we're watching this,
ladies and gentlemen who are just listening.
It's probably boring as fuck for you,
but,
um,
Jordan Burroughs is,
uh,
one of the best wrestlers.
Really.
America's ever produced three time world champion.
I tragically lost in the previous Olympics and he's back at it again.
But wonder if he's ever considered MMA.
I know he handled,
there was some talk about it,
but I wonder if we ever really,
I think at this point he's,
he is basically a no,
but there are a few terrifying people,
especially on the Russian side that I,
that I think the heavyweight division and I'm a,
and UFC should let you,
should be really worried.
I don't know if you heard about the,
the Russian tank,
the 22 year olds from Dagestan knows this guy is a wrestler at rest there and
he's going to fight MMA.
No,
he's,
he's uh,
he will after 2020 is what his expectation is for now.
He's probably going to be the greatest wrestler of all time.
Really him against Kyle Snyder,
those two heavyweights as a Merritt College,
not as American and another guy right here.
20 the tank of Dagestan.
How'd you say his name?
Uh,
it says out don't rush.
July of [inaudible] Abdulla Rasheed said ally of 22 years old.
Rashid's Snyder.
You can do call Snyder versus what a great name.
Abdul Rashid's on a lie of that alive.
That this Russian as Snyder is 23 years old and he's another incredible person
who will do MMA.
And that competition between Snyder,
uh,
I mean this is,
look at the look,
the look of the thickness.
These guys are monsters and they're not just how much these guys way I uh,
97 kilograms.
What does that to 20?
Yeah.
Two 20 under two to 15.
But they cut for it,
right?
Just under heavyweight guys.
What do you think they would compete at two oh five.
If they're going to fight in MMA,
these are heavyweights cause so that we just don't remember it in the weight.
These are still boys.
Oh 22.
Right,
right.
They still haven't gotten the full like,
yeah.
I wonder that about UFC fighters that are thickening up as they get older.
I wonder how many of them are damaging their body by cutting weight.
Yeah,
that's a thing fellow.
So,
um,
right now we're just seeing mostly stalemate and that's uh,
from,
uh,
the American guy and the,
yeah.
Is there like a highlight reel of his or something that we could,
there is,
but he's pretty young.
He's a,
I think he's a seasoned Olympic champion,
and he goes from the whole line of,
um,
the [inaudible] brothers and the all the Dagestani wrestlers.